all right let's begin this hour with
rising tensions over russia's military
buildup near ukraine and fears an
invasion may be imminent secretary of
state anthony blinken made a passionate
speech before the u.n yesterday warning
moscow could fake a pretext for war he
is now in germany along with vice
president kamala harris for talks with
u.s allies christina rafini is in munich
christina good morning
good morning vlad the annual security
conference was supposed to be scaled
back it was going to be a lower key
affair this year due to covet
restrictions but with russia's military
build up in eastern europe all the focus
has shifted to the world leaders here in
munich where from the hotel gift shop to
the well-guarded meeting rooms behind me
there's only one topic at the top of
everyone's agenda and that's ukraine
vice president kamala harris arrived
just a little while ago where she met
with the nato secretary general and
she's slated to meet with ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky sometime
this weekend now it's a risky move
leaving his country when as many as 190
000 russian troops are moving into
battle positions along ukraine's border
but zylenski wants to make sure other
world leaders aren't making decisions
about him without him now the vice
president will not be meeting with any
russian officials this weekend that's
because the russian delegation opted not
to come knowing they would be the center
of attention maybe some bad attention
either way secretary blinken took a bit
of a detour before coming to munich at
that surprise speech the united nations
security council yesterday he warned
once again that russia could be
preparing a false flag operation and
said russian media is already setting
the stage making fake claims that
ukraine is planning a genocide of ethnic
russian speakers near the country's
eastern border now overnight the state
department announced that secretary
blinken will be meeting with his russian
counterpart sergey lavrov in europe
sometime next week a good sign that
although the situation isn't getting any
better it might not necessarily get
worse at least before these two men meet
face-to-face nate christina ruffini in
munich thank you